[Applaudissements]
oh
et tous les soirs et tous les soirs il y
aura une mise en scène pour l'ours coup
de massue et je suis n'est pas dit c'est
qu'à partir de demain le chroniqueur qui
aura la plus mauvaise note des
téléspectateurs fera partie de la mise
en scène c'est bien si ça m'était hier
il y aurait eu un goût qui serait voilà
n'en est hélas elle un accord qui aura
la plus mauvaise note
on le saura bien sûr à la fin de
l'émission est celui qui aura la
meilleure note aura un magnifique cadeau
je vous le dis puisque son salaire tu
seras serein j'ai pas encore la
confirmation on est en train de faire
les gars partie interne écoute pour
l'instant on ne pas faire je valide
j'aime beaucoup de concepts félicite
alors nous avons intérêt à avoir un bon
ce coup franc sur la tête de ma mère a
feeling le chef du sud à vous me dites
la vérité
si vous aimez ou pas c'est un scoop
merci les gars merci merci beaucoup
by the saints
[Applaudissements]
on va annoncer ce monde c'est la
révélation du jour là il servait il faut
les boss vous qu'elle aborde série si
vous nous rejoignez on est en direct
c'est le scoop de matching à nice et le
premier scoop
depuis la toussaint oh oui oui c'est
vrai ah oui oui bah oui c'est normal on
redémarre
attention concentration après avoir
exploré le monde en rendez vous en terre
inconnue frédéric lebel se pare à la
recherche à la découverte de la france
dans rendez vous en france sur france 2
et pour le premier numéro un c'est ça le
scoop ouais pour le premier numéro les
chéris de cette nouvelle émission rendez
vous en terre inconnue non attends
rendez vous en terre inconnue maintenant
c'est danser en français ils vont aller
vraiment dans des endroits formidable en
france à votre avis qui est le premier
invité ceux qui savent ne lis pas alors
pour me poser des questions franchement
j'ai eu l'info tout à l'heure et ce à
quoi ces coûts avaient commencé le vôtre
non c'est qu'on sait c'est pas je vais
donner le prénom elle a donné de nom ce
n'est pas un animateur chanteur
non oui un acteur oui c'est un mec est
ce qui fait partie des cinquante
personnalités préférées des français
non mais il va devoir en faire partie
est ce que c'est un de vos copains
oui très bons amis est-ce que tout dans
des comédies
oui eux à l'umq est un blues yemelin
opus à qui je pense est finie place au
nom mais mer cimer au passé tout à
l'heure en voiture au fait allez vous
garer
[Applaudissements]
oui très drôle hubert non gaston bid est
ce qu'ils aiment le foot
oui à guy malik bentalha malik bentalha
très vite à la nba et je vis je valais
qu'il ya vraiment un ami très proche et
le polir ne monte pas digne son est le
vrai scoop c'est même pas lui qui me l'a
donnée nazi parce que j'ai mené mon
enquête après ce seront diffusion en
mars sur france 2 sera la nouvelle
émission de frédéric lopez en prime time
en prime time exactement et je pense que
malick et frédéric lopez ça va être un
énorme carton
je vous le dis il m'a dit qu à 1005 sur
les réseaux sociaux des moyens il m'a
dit que c'était incroyable ils ont été
dans un chalet un moment ils donc tous
les deux dans un truc de 1 mètre carré
et immo dit il m'a dit ne manquez pas
toutes les séquences qui a eu parce que
c'était fou manic dans cet exercice but
exceptionnel et hyper drôle moi en plus
à dax et qui va sortir il est fou de
dans des extraits de taxi j'ai eu la
chance de voir des petites scènes parce
que franck m'ont envoyé franck
gastambide il est exceptionnel dans taxi
malik je pense que là ça va être un
énorme carton vous n'aimez pas que ce
qui se passe maintenant en fait j'aime
beaucoup malik bentalha mais je pense
que ça ne correspond pas au public de
france 2 c'est ça le problème moi je
pense que justement c'est très malin
parce que frédéric lopez va mener son
public et il ya un autre public qui va
venir voir malik franches mais qui m'a
regardé ici sont déjà c'est en france et
moi j'ai toujours dit qu'ils avaient des
coire en france extraordinaire est allé
au parking devant l'intérêt drôle ceci
ces rendez-vous en picardie savait alors
pas du tout ça il serait bien des
endroits
ce sera dans les cévennes ont été bonnes
avec bâti à la découverte des gens mais
ou pas oui bien sûr évidemment
aujourd'hui
ah oui on a envie de voir mike bentalha
là dedans à brest il fait partie de
second degré en plus très bon guerrier
super drôle et surtout il est très
bienveillant donc il a les deux
ingrédients parfaits pour ce genre
d'émission